[Music]
it is
me and I have got this moral
Ben I love my
mother I hate my
brother so let's get after it and have
us a good
time good [__] bread [__]
bread uh
well Vivic was on comoo
show I would find it hard to believe
that went well but okay not for comoo
because what I'm saying viic is
annoying yeah but I kind of like it no
no no no I'm not saying it in a bad way
but he's annoying like he's he's just he
needles you right like when he goes your
exactly your daughter's on Tik Tok ho
what are you going to do
[__] you're honestly there's a certain
element of that he has like that I would
compare to Tucker yeah because I I've
been saying for years Tucker is a guy I
would [__] jump over a desk at and
try to collar him like if he was like
aiming that Tucker at me like there's
just times when like like same thing
with Tucker he'll needle somebody like
if I were the politician like via
satellite I'd be flipping him off I'd be
like you know what [__] you man be
ripping mics off I don't and look I
don't want him to be president I think
he's a snake I think he's a snake oil
salesman so let me be CLE I want I just
want Vivic to just keep throwing
grenades at everybody I don't want him
to have any kind of power because it's
funny look what he got Chris cuom to
admit ramas Swami why do you keep going
at Niki Haley why do you think this is
going to Chris I don't know what you've
been smoking man you and the rest of the
mainstream media it's laughable Nikki
Haley has been going after me the whole
campaign first debate second debate you
know she's been trailing me for much of
the time but I realize the establishment
media has realized that there's a puppet
they want to put up I'm not playing that
game the Grassroots of this country know
they want a leader who isn't going to
send us our sons and daughters to go die
in Foreign Wars that racked up 7
trillion in debt Dick Cheney 2.0's
taking over the GOP problem is the
Democratic establishment media is now
rooting for War I I'm the only candidate
speaking for a true America First agenda
on that debate stage and I think we're
going to be
successful so far Chris com's stupid he
doesn't know what he said but it get it
gets fun Viv how you gonna bring people
together when you just uh put together a
tapestry of conspiracies says the guy
that did the Russia gay thing that did
the piss gate thing says the guy who at
one point and I just saw this clip on
Twitter going around again where he said
that half of the country are our enemies
because they won't get vaccinated
correct correct remember the big
Q-tips you know that I'm not pitching
anything about come on
my It's News Nation it's barely a show
so yeah it's not really it's it's you
know she won't even come on my show what
are you talking about second hold on a
second I let you I let you put it out
there and now you know but you need him
more than he needs you at this point
again let's be honest com here's the
thing you let him put one statement out
there and then you called him a
conspiracy theorist and now you're
trying to [__] filibuster let him
answer the point that he's conspiracy
theorist I get to finish smoking and uh
now I get to answer which is um oh this
is what the me this what do you smoking
bugged them by the way that's why I made
that joke is doing is putting up Nikki
Haley against me because they know I'm
the real deal please she hasn't even
been on my show I'm just watching you
get slapped around can I ask can I ask
wait wait wait he
he thinks that he is getting slapped
around by her I'm sorry we don't like
any of these people but we saw that
debate it was the other way
around also he's like acting like Vivic
just making up these conspiracies when
we went to the GOP debates and sat down
and we saw the way the staging was and
we saw how like you know the the the the
sections were and who were allowed to be
noisy and [__] like me and Roy turned to
each other and like we're like
dude they really want [__] Nikki
Haley huh like it wasn't before Vivic
said anything we just arrived at that
conclusion like wow they are really
propping Haley up to be the candidate
for some reason and nobody wants her
he's not wrong
yeah wonder your strateg the fact of the
matter is Chris my strategy is calling
out the mainstream media like I did to
Kristen Welker at the started that
debate I asked her about the Trump
Russia collusion hoax told her to look
the audience in the eye and apologize to
them just like I'll tell you you're part
of the mainstream media despite
pretending like you're not look the
audience in the eye and tell mother for
do you like him do you like him I'm part
of the mainstream media yeah I am yes I
am that nobody wants to be known as part
of the mainstream media it's not even a
good term but he wants to be part of the
club so yes I am part of the club you're
not you're not your network is on
YouTube brother for all that happened
okay listen to the brother question here
you go here you go where get
fun brother for all that happened of the
main media and you play the same games
that the rest of the mainstream take
your doing it tonight you've been you
have been you have been covered for your
brother you have been playing a game you
kicked off for my
brother of course no of course I covered
for my brother here's the problem you're
trying to sue CNN now for the remainder
of the money on your
contract and now you admitted to you did
cuz he is unless unless they settled
unless they've settled I I believe he
was trying to sue him for a big portion
of the
contract
oh I think he was trying to sue him for
more than his contract wasn't he trying
to go for some wrongful termination I
want to say it was like 14 mil I want to
say 14 mil oh
buddy
so yeah doing it tonight you've been you
have been you have been for your brother
you have been playing a game
you of course I help
my don't say it you idiot you're a
journalist you're not supposed to him of
course I of course I withheld
information about my criminal family
yeah obviously my dad was in the
mafia what do you think we were gonna do
it's kind of baked into the cake
here you know what that's been
journalistic standards that have now
been failed not just by you but by every
m M of the broken political media so yes
it is going to
take and you want to look everyone in
the media is responsible for covering
for my brother see what I'm saying you
miss yeah no no no you're responsible
for covering for your brother mhm you
just said so that's but not what he he
didn't say that 90% of the media
colluding pushing one one I'm going too
broad says the guy who was just fired
from CNN yeah and and says the guy whose
uh brother isn't a governor anymore cuz
he groped two broads yeah so honestly
the father was in the mafia and on the
American public for the origin or at
least in the mafia's pocket covid-19 to
the hunter Biden laptop
story deci they want what does this have
to do with Nikki
Haley over here he's such a
[__] he's one of the stupidest people
I know he has to be one of the dumbest
people wow he got he's such an idiot he
immediately yeah I did cover for my
brother of course I did why did he think
he was gonna hold his own against Vivic
like I would be if if somebody smarter
than Cuomo thought that they were gonna
hold their own like go you sure you're
going to be able to hold your own I as
just [__]
lunatic